hi and welcome to cloud on air live
webinars from Google cloud we're hosting
webinars every Tuesday my name is
Jonathan Shetty I'm the product manager
for genomics and life sciences at Google
cloud today were we talking about
powering genomics research on Google
cloud platform you can ask questions
anytime on the platform we have good
word on standby it to answer them let's
get started so a few topics we're going
to talk about today first I'm gonna tell
you a little bit about how you can
accomplish genomic and clinical data
mining together using bigquery then I'll
tell you a little bit about how you can
run batch workflows at scale using
pipeline's API then I'll hand it over to
my friend Geraldine from the Broad
Institute tell you a bit about gta4 and
the fire cloud platform she'll also tell
you about how their team optimized gta4
for Google cloud and then Keith from
Google will tell you a bit about some of
the really cool innovations that are
happening right here at GCP but first I
want to tell you a little bit about the
team that I'm part of this is a team
that started at Google just last year
it's called the cloud for health Life
Sciences team we've brought together
product managers software engineers
solution architects and a commercial
team to help organizations do all sorts
of amazing things with health and life
sciences data using Google cloud whether
it's an academic institution whether
it's a pharma company a provider a payer
health products or services company we
want to help you use any kind of health
and life science data type in Google
cloud more effectively in particular the
product teams dyma part of our focused
on a few key modalities clinical data so
EMR data EHR data other kinds of
phenotypic data sets imaging data that's
DICOM PACs PET scans MRIs x-rays in my
team the genomics and Life Sciences team
where we're dealing with not only
genomic data but all kinds of other
biomedical data sets so it could be
microbiome RNA seek
and others flow cytometry why we're
doing this is because our vision is that
there's going to be a conversions of
these data types in the cloud where for
whatever sample you're working with
whether it's yeast or an entire human
population it'll be helpful for you to
be able to analyze data across these
different modalities together and that's
what we're enabling so let's talk a bit
about what that can look like especially
coming from the genomics and life
sciences point of view so one of the
products from my team is called variant
transforms variant transforms is an
open-source tool to help you manage your
genomic data using bigquery you can
think about it as a way to take your VCF
sfrom
panels exomes or genomes and import them
directly into bigquery using the inherit
VCF schema you're presenting from there
you can do things like calculate your
allele frequency or build a cohort or do
ad hoc exploration of that data set but
I think we all know that we're these
these kind of data sets get really
exciting is when we join them with other
kinds of data so that's exactly what
company called color in the Bay Area did
I want to tell you a little bit more
about that so color is a health services
company they offer very affordable and
accessible genetic testing and they have
a 30 gene panel in cancer and they also
had an existing database of phenotypic
data some health history data and report
data that was sitting at Postgres
database the problem they had is that
they wanted to be able to expand that
test by mining the raw sequence data
alongside the other data they had
available on those samples the cloud
prior they had been using up till now
didn't really have a mature enough
managed data warehouse solution like
bigquery which is so great for these
kinds of scalable queries so what they
do they used variant transforms as I
mentioned totally open source tool for
bringing all of that data into bigquery
they took the data from the Postgres
database which had a bunch of biomarker
information
and put that in bigquery and joined it
together on top of that their data
scientists have stood up all kinds of
really cool machine learning tools and
built a whole bunch of great great
models so what happened well they got
all the feature engineering done in one
week and they created three novel models
that outperformed an existing major
clinical model for predicting certain
biomarkers in fact they are test which
is actually designed for cancer they
found out worked in a completely
unrelated therapeutic area this is
really exciting it may become public a
ssin may become a novel test but we're
really excited about the kinds of result
that our customers are achieving by
joining their genomic data with other
data types using bigquery so I'm going
to switch gears for a minute here from
tertiary analysis to secondary analysis
no doubt if you're watching this you're
probably processing lots of samples
perhaps in a cloud environment perhaps
somewhere else and you're thinking about
how you can really scale up that work of
your pipeline of your pipelines so our
team also offers a API called not
surprisingly pipeline's API pipeline's
API helps you run bioinformatics
pipelines at scale in cheating great
metrics around turnaround time and cost
you can stand up all kinds of great
industry standard tools like gtk which
you're going to hear more about and you
can optimize for parallel execution and
you can leverage a lot of great
innovations in Google Cloud like
preemptable virtual machines GPUs
regional storage you're gonna hear a
little bit more about that later today
we've also brought together a phenomenal
ecosystem of platform partners and
workflow engines to help you with all
this so soon you're going to hear more
about rode Institute and their fire
cloud platform you'll also hear about
the Cromwell open source workflow engine
which are great ways of running your
workflows and leveraging the power of
pipeline's API we also have other
partners such as mooji next code DNA
stack seven bridges and the next slow
open source workflow engine
the kinds of results that people get
from leveraging pipeline's API is this
kind of massive scale so for example the
team at Stanford School of Medicine is
running be able to run thousands of
genomes in parallel what today they say
feels like infinite resources and be
able to boot up a lot of machines at
once to accomplish with batch workflow
in a very short period of time while
still focusing on low cost our friend
the Broad have used pipeline's API quite
a bit to the shall we say they process
over two hundred and fifty genomes every
single day they are now working with
over 35 petabytes of data in Google
Cloud and just last year consumed over
100 million compute core hours and
they're scaling up their work because of
the innovation within pipeline's API so
we'll talk a little bit about some of
the work that they're doing the broad
nomad team recently called variants on
the nomad data set with the grch38
reference and the problem they had was
that Nomad as you might know 79,000
whole genomes that were previously
called with hg19 they wanted to be able
to call variants for that entire data
set using gatk 4 and grch38 so they were
able to spin up 79,000 workflows and
call the variants for the entire data
set in three days it's a really exciting
result and i think there's a great
example of the kind of scale you can
achieve using pipeline's API and engine
such as Cromwell and platforms such as
fire cloud so what's next for that team
they're going to be calling variants for
exome data on Nomad as well again using
some of the same technologies and
techniques so speaking of innovations
through the pipeline's API just last
month we released a brand new version of
pipeline's API for our ecosystem of
platform partners and workflow engines
what's new well first you're able to run
multiple docker containers for instance
this is really helpful because you can
now run service containers in the
background while workflow is running in
progress we also make it a lot easier
for to authors field to inject
and containers around a workflow
localization and D localization of files
is much much simpler it's just now a
container instruction and there's also
profit I favorite feature a lot more
information is available to our platform
partners and workflow engine partners on
the information about the transition
between states so that in M failure
modes so for example when I have a
pipeline that fails why did it fail did
it run out of memory did it simply crash
something happened to the node some how
did I get preempted that information was
a little hard to access before and now
it's much easier and good provides a
better experience for whatever workflow
engine or platform you're using we've
also made it easier to specify regions
in zones and much of you to specify the
minimum CPU platform options Keith will
tell you a little bit more about that
soon in terms of how you can bring up
custom VMs so all this great talk about
secondary analysis let's learn a little
bit more about how people are doing this
in the real world so now I'm going to
invite up my friend Geraldine from the
road tell you more about gta4 and
firecloud
thanks Jonathan its playroom in here I'm
going to talk today about gta4 and
firecloud and the way we have been
working to make our pipelines available
accessible to the wider community of
researchers now first I want to start
with a little bit of recap of what is
JDK exactly what that's covers so JDK is
it genomic analysis toolkit and this is
roughly the process for genomic analysis
specifically with a focus on variant
discovery if you think that you're
starting with biological material for
example blood samples we're going to
extract DNA from that put that to the
sequencing machine right that's going to
produce a huge pile of short reads that
those short reads that's the raw data
that we're going to be using in our
pipelines the end result that we want to
get to is a list of variation mutations
in the individual genome or genomes of a
group of individuals and so the pipeline
which is what change key constitutes is
going to take that raw data do some
clean up do some mapping to find out
where the reads belong in the genome and
then do the analysis that enables us to
identify those variations those
mutations in individual genomes which is
ultimately what researcher cares about
now these tools have been around for a
long time about a decade which honestly
in genomics time is pretty much at like
a century and for a long time they were
evolving kind of naturally were just
improving the our ability to just push
the scientific boundaries of what we
could identify now over the last few
years as Jonathan mentioned there's been
a huge explosion in the the size of the
genomic data and the data sets that we
need to be able to analyze
and so we've put a lot of work into
making sure that's the tools and
pipelines can cope with that huge
explosion in the size of datasets and
specifically we built what we call gatk
floor which is version 4 of the GTA
toolkits I'm not going to go into a
detailed laundry list of features but
the main themes are that we've really
improved the the technical performance
speed and scalability of the tools and
that has involved a complete rewrite
we've rewritten that entire software
code mates from scratch to be able to
cope with the demands of the genomics
workloads that are now today's reality
but it's not just it's not just about
the technical performance well that's
very important but we've also put a lot
of work into expanding the scope of
analysis to be able to cover more
variant types so where previously we
were very focused on germline short
variance it was kind of what we were
known for now we've expanded that to
cover all the major variant classes
including copy number structural
variation in both journey line and
somatic mutations so we're now able to
cover almost all of these these use
cases and the remaining one that's it's
not quite implemented today somatic
structural variation is planned and we
have that on the roadmap we hope to
deliver that later this year and so the
idea is that you have all these
pipelines that allow you to really do
all the scientific work that you need
related to variant discovery now the
thing is and there's there's been two
big pushes in that direction one is just
developing the right methods to produce
those those end results but also improve
the speed and performance of the tools
right and that has involved leveraging a
lot of
the improvements in for example machine
learning that have really flourished
over the past few years now if we look
at these pipelines all of them involve a
sizeable number of steps involving
different tools and for the individual
researchers it's not it's not easy to
implement this at scale and so one of
the things we've been focused on lately
is formalizing pipeline definitions
which we call the GTA best practices
which researcher can take and apply to
their data without having to figure out
by themselves how to implement this so
we call that the GTA best practices
pipelines but there's still a big step
between having the pipeline definitions
and and being able to implement that so
we've gone a step further and now we're
making available these pipelines as
ready to run render on pipelines that
are in preloaded in a platform that we
call firecloud trends on Google cloud
and so we have these workspaces that
contain the pipeline as well as example
data and so anyone can go and clone one
of those workspaces run the pipeline as
it is pre-configured on an example data
they can also upload their own data and
run the pipeline on their own data and
that way you have the JTA best practices
pipelines just available in ready to run
state out of the box so hopefully I've
got you interested now I want to tell
you a little bit more about fire clouds
platform itself
ok so fire cloud is meant to be a
self-service analysis portal that
anybody can access and specifically
anybody can access for free so we built
this originally from the broad
researchers but we make this available
for freedom of course it's using Google
cloud resources so you still have to pay
Google cloud for storage and compute
costs things like that but we do have a
free credits program that you can use to
get started with the
for him to test it out without taking
any financial risk yourself now the the
platform itself offers a number of
services including the ability to manage
your data to share your data securely
and to run workflows on your data so
we've got a number of pipelines there
are presets that you can run on your
data in this platform but you can also
bring your own pipelines either
variations of ours or just different
workloads that you need to run because
we understand that many people use other
tools besides ghk and we can use this
through the web portal which is a
graphical user interface you can also
use it through the API if you prefer to
interact programmatically with the
platform and as of last week we also
have now the ability to spin up Jupiter
notebooks on spark clusters so you can
follow up your batch execution your
pipeline execution with interactive
analysis of the results that they
produce now let's look a little bit
closer more closely at how batch
execution of workflows works in fire lab
don't worry about the details yet but
let's look at the overall system here we
have two researchers who have access to
this workspace the workspace
encapsulated encapsulate everything
that's involved in a particular project
including the definition of the data
that's involved and the methods and
that's also the place where you're going
to be executing pipelines so you also
have access to pipelines who workflows
that's the stack of scripts that you see
above the workspace and you have a
number of data buckets that are
available now the way it works is that
the data is stored in the buckets so
your data is going to live in Google
storage either associated with the
workspace or in other buckets and you
can also compute on data that's
elsewhere in the data library which are
public data
they're providing the workflows are
Whittle scripts Woodall is a workflow
definition language the gatk pipelines
are all provided as pre-loaded Wordle
scripts and that contains the definition
of your actual workflows now when you go
to run a workflow on your data all you
need to do really is connect the
workflow with the inputs the inputs
that's the data that's defined in your
data model which describes what files
you have available and how they plug
into the workflow so you have your you
have your data definition you're going
to launch one of these workflows on your
data that's going to be handed off to on
the backend to Chrome well which is the
execution engine and Cromwell is going
to take care of everything for you so
it's going to execute your workflow talk
to the pipeline's API which Jonathan
talked about and run your workflow on
the Google compute engine and then write
back the outputs to your workspace data
backing so that's how you run a pipeline
in pipe lab and specifically if you're
using one of the gtk best practices
pipeline which is pre-loaded you can get
started with this very quickly and it's
abstracts away all the difficulties of
implementing um these kinds of
complicated pipelines on the cloud and
what's really neat is like I said as of
last week you can follow up and use the
results that you have now you can intro
you can explore your results
interactively in the Jupiter notebooks
alright so that shows you how to access
and run the ghk pipelines and fire cloud
let's talk a little bit about what it
costs because when we started migrating
our workflows to the Google platform it
became clear to us that there were some
great opportunities to cut down the cost
of operation and here I'm going to talk
briefly about the various strategies
that we used to bring down dramatically
the cost of operating our genome
analysis pipeline now the the main
strategies that we used and we developed
this with quite a lot of friends quite a
lot of help from our friends at Google
have been in several different
categories one was this idea of task
splitting and persistent disk now that's
the idea here is that when you have your
tasks in a workflow you're allocating
for each task you're allocating some
resources some disk size some processor
size and the beefy or the machine the
bigger the disk the more you're going to
pay for this hardware and so what you
want to do is make sure that the
allocation is commensurate with the
needs of your task and we have found
that there are various ways that we can
optimize how tasks are either split up
or bundled together depending on what
their computational requirements are and
what is the size of the inputs and
outputs that we need to store locally to
really optimize the allocation resource
requests now the other in that panic
goes with it
the other big strategy and this is
personally my favorites that we've
applied to bring down the cost is the
use of preemptable VMs preemptable VMs
are machines where you you get them at a
really steep discount you pay you know
20% of the normal price for a machine
but that comes with the understanding
that you can get kicked off the machine
at any time so for really long running
jobs that's not so desirable but if
you're running really short jobs or to a
few hours it's actually really good deal
because you're paying a lot less for the
computes
and there's some logic built in so that
if you do get kicked off the machine
there will be some automatic retries and
you can even tune how many attempts you
want to do on priam tables before
defaulting back to regular machine that
you have for sure and so by doing that
and by switching virtually all the steps
in our pipelines to use in preemptable
VMS we've gained an additional 35
percent savings on the cost of running
our team and pipeline and now the final
piece in the puzzle the the last big
strategy that we've applied to cut down
costs of our pipeline operation is to be
really smart about how we're accessing
the data JP Martin at very life science
contributed some really valuable code to
HTS JDK which is an open source library
that underlies cheat K it's what JDK
uses to read in and write out files and
that's that the code that JP contributed
allows us to reads data directly from
the bucket instead of having to copy the
file to the local disk before we can
compute on it
and that makes big difference because
for example if we're if we're
parallelizing across genomic regions if
you're you think that normally you would
have to copy an entire genome damn file
to local disk right but now you can skip
that and just copy the little piece of
data that you're actually doing one on
that allows you to go much faster
because you don't have to wait for 100
Gig BAM file to get copied and it also
allows you to allocate a much smaller
disk space so that ties into the first
strategy that I mentioned where we can
use much smaller disks for each task
if you're thinking well this is going to
be used across thousands or tens of
thousands of genomic intervals and then
replicated across tens or tens of
thousands of genomes themselves that
amounts to fairly significant savings
again in this case 15% savings on the
total cost of the pipeline and the
results of all of that in aggregates is
that from an initial cost of $45 per
genome to process an entire genome on
cloud we've cut that down to $5 per
genome and the we've done some
additional tweaking that I can share
we're seeing now that's with some of
those additional tweaks we can actually
bring down the cost of the pipeline
right now to three dollars and
sixty-five cents per genome so that just
gives us so much more bang for our
research but it's it has made a huge
difference in terms of what we can do at
the front Institute with our dream with
pipelines I want to be clear that we're
still offering best practices pipelines
that are generic that can run anywhere
but we have this version of the gt4
pipelines that is very optimized very
deeply optimized for Google Cloud it's
what we run in production we make that
available so that everybody can benefit
from this optimizing work you can try
this pipeline in firecloud it's
preloaded in the workspace that lives at
the URL that's on your screen the $5
genome analysis pipeline which we might
have to update the name of to the three
dollar genome pipeline and hopefully
that will just keep going down so that
covers the work that we've done so far
with ggk and five lab I'm going to throw
it over to my friend Keith from Google I
was going to talk about
platform innovation great thanks
Geraldine so innovation is something
that we hold dearly at Google and as you
heard from Jonathan and Geraldine our
innovation stems from things like the
pipeline's API to bigquery even to stuff
like preemptable VMs it's fascinating to
think that for the price of a cup of
coffee in New York you can do an entire
genome analysis to me that's amazing
but our innovation doesn't just stop
there
at Google we don't believe you should
simply lift your workload or application
into the cloud we believe that you
should lift shift and improve upon that
workload in application and the
improvements take form of some of the
cost innovation and technical innovation
that we have for instance we have a live
migration capability so your instances
can seamlessly migrate to a machine
during maintenance windows without any
user intervention and without any
planned downtime this is something we
took advantage of during the recent
spectrum meltdown vulnerabilities
whereby we migrated our entire customer
environment seamlessly without them
having to be involved in order to
address that vulnerability additionally
we have custom machine types so we know
that applications sometimes don't fall
into a specific ratio of CPU and memory
so we allow you to define what that
ratio is maybe you need four cores an 80
gig of ram we don't stop you from doing
that
additionally we have recommendations
using our vast history of machine
learning to look at how an instance is
performed
and say you know what if you change the
core count on this machine or maybe
reduce this the memory footprint not
only will your instance still run but
you'll save a couple dollars as well we
believe that you should pay for what you
consume and to that end we have per
second billing so if your instance runs
for 73 seconds you're gonna pay for 73
seconds you're not gonna pay for 120
seconds or even more we also have
extremely fast start ups for our
instances we're talking about a matter
of seconds so let's get you up and
running as fast as possible and lastly
we allow you to resize your discs
on-the-fly if you need a bigger disk we
allow you to do that seamlessly as well
as increasing the I ops for that disk as
you make it bigger
now innovation isn't only about
technology and cost we think security is
also a strategic part of innovation at
Google cloud and it starts with you the
customer by default without you having
to do anything all of your data in
transit and at rest is encrypted you
don't have to worry about any PKI
infrastructure you don't have to worry
about any key management now of course
if you are a type that likes to manage
your own keys we allow you to do that
but knowing that you don't have to do
that is an extremely extremely important
benefit and this notion of security and
encryption extends into our cloud stack
it starts at the silicon level we made
our own in-house secure chip that we put
on every peripheral device and that
secure chip will check to make sure that
it's a trusted root during boot if it
detects any abnormality during the
manufacturing cycle
or even during steady-state that machine
in our data center will not boot and
will be reported to our engineers that
extends into our server environment we
have our own custom servers that we
manufacturer and having the ability to
to make our own servers we eliminate all
the extraneous stuff that you may have
in a server from off the shelf we don't
necessarily have to put in video cards
if they're not needed so not only do we
free up valuable real estate on that
server to introduce additional CPU and
RAM but we're actually eliminating a
threat vector by eliminating potential
vulnerabilities in those peripheral
devices that you don't even need we also
extend this to our storage environment
and our network environment they are
both custom and allow us to own not only
the hardware but the software and the
firmware stack as well and lastly at a
holistic level our data centers have
both logical and physical security to
that end because we own the hardware the
software and the firmware we're not
reliant upon any third party to provide
patches in case of a vulnerability as we
control it we can issue those patches as
soon as possible now you don't have to
take our word for it now we do annual
audits with our third party consultants
to test the attestation of our
environment and when it comes to
genomics and the life sciences that one
certification that you may see on the
bottom left is of utmost importance and
that's HIPPA with Google our entire
cloud environment is HIPAA certified
which means you don't have to worry
about selecting a certain cloud or
instance to put that Pho data as long as
you put it on Google Cloud
it's automatically covered by our HIPAA
certification and you can see we have a
vast amount of other certifications as
well such as PCI FedRAMP etc and lastly
innovation is not about keeping all of
it close to the chest we are a firm
proponent of the open source community
to that end we've incubated numerous
projects within Google that we've
released to the open source environment
two of those projects in particular
kubernetes for container orchestration
and tensorflow
for machine learning are the number one
and number two highest engagement in all
of github and not only do we incubate
products and release them to the open
source community but our employees are
Googlers also are active contributors as
of 2017 there are eleven hundred
projects in github contributed by
Googlers and those Googlers totaled over
nine hundred employees
so stay tuned for a live Q&A we'll be
back in less than a minute
you
all right we're back all right some
questions from the audience so I've been
told this first question comes from a
hey-zeus Gomez in New York who asks do I
have to bid for preemptable instances
yeah the answer is no the this is a big
difference with Google cloud and that
you don't have to bid for preemptable
instances you just select them and
pipeline's API provides an option for
you to employ both preemptable CPUs and
preemptable GPUs you just use them you
get the discount and you go to work and
that's a flat 80% off for all instances
and GPUs is a flat 50% so definitely
take advantage of that how do I get
started with fire club yeah fire cloud
org is the URL that you're looking for
and you can make an account you get
actually get $250 in credits just to get
started so that's quite a few genomes as
you've heard about some of the really
cool cost work that's being done by
froude yeah and you know I have a GC P
instance I know firecloud runs on GC p
do I have to create a new billing
account right how do I get my you know
procurement team involved can I can I
use my existing account with firecloud
you actually can there's instructions on
how to do this both on our blog and on
the firecloud site so you can bring your
own GCP billing account you can supply
the billing account ID and then the
charge for all that compute goes to your
home institution so you're really
getting all the benefits of firecloud
you're getting all the benefits of the
optimizations and yet it's your home
institution that's getting charged you
don't have to worry about doing a
transaction with bro excellent this is a
five dollar genome include alignment or
is this just jdk crate quest for a
question so the answer is yes so five
dollars gets you
yes that's fast Q to VCF it's the
quality metrics so it's
alignment and variant calling it's
really exciting I mean just I mean when
we're talking on a secondary analysis
there's so much innovation happening in
this field especially from a cost
perspective we see ghk it is really
funny to think that was really just a
couple years ago that was 10 times more
expensive 9 to 10 times more expensive
and now we're talking about it I think a
lot of the buzz in our industry is
always about the $1,000 genome and being
able to generate they did cheaply but
bring down the cost by 10x is pretty
significant to on the informatics side
so I I think that as we watch this field
we're gonna see the cost of secondary
analysis get closer and closer to the
zero which is something I'm personally
excited about because I think it unlock
unleashes all kinds of new research
questions and opportunities it sounds
like we'll be at three dollars very soon
exactly yeah which I guess leads us to
how how would I get started with JDK 4
yeah we're jtk hope exactly so so again
if you want to run on the fire cloud
platform fire cloud org also if you want
to get started using GTA 4 we've also
put Doc's on our website so if you go to
cloud google.com slash genomics /g e TK
you'll see Doc's there that help you
just get up and running on a sample
right away and I believe the broad
website also and the broad website has
some where URL as well and their walk
yeah
so we both both institutions have
blogged about this it's just it's such
an exciting development for the
community and if all else fails you can
google it yes we have a search engine
recommend here how would I get started
with variant transforms so barring
transforms as you heard of I'm so
excited about the work that's already
being done with it you getting sort of
the out-of-the-box variant database
based on bigquery which is such a
powerful technology so variant
transforms it's on our github page the
URL is a little tricky so probably
Google that but not only if you go to
the variant transforms github site
you'll see not
just the code not just documentation
you'll see our product roadmap we've
actually open sourced the product
roadmap as well you'll see the work that
we're doing to add annotation support
you'll see the work that we're doing to
add a big crate to VCF pipeline because
sometimes you might be selecting a
cohort based on all the data you've
emerged and you want to go back to VCS
you can use some file based tools so
that's on the roadmap as well would
really look forward to folks commenting
on that we really do look at that page
and it does inform our product
development on varying transforms so
another great example of contributing to
the open source exactly like community
exactly we realized that it was so
important to make that open source it's
also written in Python like many other
stages of bioinformatics pipelines and
by open source again we know that folks
will have their own VCF schemas they'll
want to be able to tweak it and we want
to just make that easier and we're
excited to give the something back to
the community in this way awesome
speaking of bigquery right you know I've
used it once or twice and I see this
thing about public datasets can you tell
me which ones are available yeah oh man
I don't know if I can recite all of them
but gosh there's a bunch so some of the
ones you might expect thousand genomes
TCGA the missing data set is an autism
research data set as they are some data
from the Simons Foundation yeah there's
the there's a whole list online and
we'll make sure to post the URL
afterwards but you can find them but
we're always interested in public
datasets that would be good for the
community and that can be very helpful
so we see that as an opportunity again
to aid the research community by hosting
those datasets for free and then
enabling folks to compute on that
dataset using some of the tools we've
been talking about here today and
speaking of tools I know your team was
at the hims conference last week at
anything
you wanna call out sure yeah
so I hims was a great opportunity for us
to introduce the healthcare API
healthcare API is actually built by our
clinical data informatics team makes it
really easy for you to deal with EMR and
EHR data in the cloud we're making we're
really interested in helping people
manage that data process it and work
with it at scale so we're getting the
signal to wrap up so thank you so much
for joining us it's been a lot of fun
and thank you for all the great question